Welcome, curious minds to The
Deep Dive.
Today we're plunging into an
idea that might sound utterly
dramatic, maybe even a bit
mythical at first.
But we've all heard that phrase,
right?
The Graveyard of Empires.
Oh yeah, definitely conjures of
all sorts of images.
Exactly.
Ancient lands, immense power
just fizzling out.
A place known for absorbing
these huge invading forces and
then kind of just shrugging them
off, leaving them totally
depleted.
The land itself basically
unchanged.
Right.
Powerless in the end.
But here's the twist we're
exploring today.
What if that same dynamic, that
really unique pattern of like
absorption and then rejection,
could actually apply to modern
America?
It's a compelling parallel,
isn't it almost unsettling when
you first hear it?
Totally.
Because, I mean, it seems so
counterintuitive.
America, you know, global
superpower, beacon of
innovation, constant change, not
some besieged nation fending off
armies.
Right.
But the author we're looking at,
Chris Abraham, in this
provocative article titled
America, Afghanistan, he argues
exactly that point and with,
well, surprising depth and a lot
of historical examples.
Yeah, he really builds a case.
Absolutely.
So for this deep dive, our
mission really is to unpack
Abraham's fascinating argument
that America, in its own very
unique way, mirrors
Afghanistan's historical role,
not against, you know, literal
invading armies with tanks and
stuff, thankfully, but against
these powerful cultural and
social movements that try to
change the country from within.
So we're going to delve into
these really striking parallels
and the specific, often kind of
unseen forces the author claims
are fundamentally at play just
beneath the surface of American
Society.
It's about understanding a
different kind of power, isn't
it?
Not like overt military might,
but something more subtle.
An enduring power of absorption,
maybe an eventual
neutralization, like a societal
immune response, if you will,
that ultimately preserves some
kind of core identity.
Yeah, that's a good way to put
it.
Given Afghanistan's remarkable,
almost mystical ability to just
outlast and eventually shed
these external forces, it leads
to this really wild question
from the article.
Could America, in its own
distinct way, be doing the exact
same thing, but doing it to
internal movements instead of
literal armies?
The source material for this
deep dive?
It lays out a fascinating, maybe
even unsettling case that really
forces you to reconsider how
societal change actually
happens.
Oh, doesn't happen.
Right.
How deep does change really go?
OK, so to really grasp Abraham's
main idea, we first need to
properly establish Afghanistan's
historical reputation.
It's not just some dramatic
nickname.
The Graveyard of Empires is,
according to this source, a
historical truth proven over and
over again through centuries.
It's a reputation earned
through, well, a really unique
kind of cultural resilience.
Precisely.
The source really emphasizes
this point.
For century, some of the most
formidable, most powerful
nations on earth have marched
into Afghanistan.
Big ones.
Huge.
They came with overwhelming
armies, cutting edge weapons for
their time, meticulous plans,
and this this fervent belief
that they could control and
fundamentally change the very
fabric of Afghan society.
Every single time.
Every single time, they were
convinced they'd be different,
that they would succeed where
everyone else had failed, that
their will, their might, their
ideology would finally bend
Afghanistan to their desires.
And the examples the article
gives are just incredibly stark.
We're talking global superpowers
at the absolute peak of their
influence.
Yeah, the big leagues.
First, think about the British
Empire, 19th, early 20th
centuries at the height of its
power, ruling like 1/4 of the
world's population.
Right.
The empire on which the sun
never set.
Exactly.
Britain tried repeatedly to
assert control over Afghanistan,
mostly strategic reasons, you
know, worried about Russia, the
Great game.
They invested immense resources,
thousands of lives, unparalleled
military might in these
campaigns that stretched on for
decades.
Yeah, multiple Anglo Afghan
wars.
Yet each time they just found
themselves bogged down this
seemingly endless conflict.
Their forces bled dry, their
political will just eroded, and
ultimately they were forced to
retreat, leaving Afghanistan
pretty much unconquered and
unbowed.
It just absorbed the punch.
Then Fast forward the Soviet
Union, late 20th century.
A different kind of superpower,
right?
Driven by communist ideology,
believing it was the future of
the world.
A world revolution narrative.
In 1979 they launched a full
scale invasion, poured billions
into this protracted, really
brutal war.
Their goal was clear.
Install a compliant communist
regime.
Fundamentally transform Afghan
society in their image.
Right.
Modernize it, secularize it,
bring it into the Soviet sphere.
They had this overwhelming
military machine, vast
resources.
They were there for a whole
decade, but they too eventually
withdrew in 1989.
Their economy strained, their
military demoralized, their
imperial ambitions just in
tatters.
The Soviet Vietnam, some called
it.
Exactly.
And they left behind a nation
that despite just immense
suffering and destruction,
largely reverted.
It went back to its pre invasion
state in terms of its core
identity, its tribal structures.
The underlying patterns just re
emerge.
And then most recently, the
United States.
After 911, the US-led this
international coalition into
Afghanistan spent trillions of
dollars.
Trillions with AT.
Fought for two decades, the
stated goals dismantle terrorist
networks, stabilize the region,
transform Afghanistan into a
stable democratic state.
A modern nation building project
on a massive scale.
The investment was colossal.
Lives treasure 2 decades of
sustained effort trying to build
institutions, change the
culture.
Yet as we all saw just a few
years ago, the ultimate outcome
was this incredibly rapid
collapse.
The new systems, the government,
the military that have been
propped up for years by foreign
aid and influence, just melted
away.
Yeah, startlingly fast.
And Afghanistan, in so many
fundamental ways just reverted,
went back to its old ways almost
instantly once the foreign
forces packed up and left.
It's this recurring theme.
Every single one of these global
giants thought they could turn
Afghanistan into what they
wanted it to be, and every
single time Afghanistan absorb
their efforts waited them out
and just went back to being
Afghanistan the moment the
foreign armies drained and
defeated.
Left.
And what's really fascinating
here, what the source
meticulously details, is how
Afghanistan's resilience works.
It isn't primarily framed as
like direct military victory on
the battlefield, though
obviously there was intense
fighting.
Sure, lots of conflict.
But instead, it's presented as
this profound cultural
absorption and eventual
rejection.
It's a very different kind of
power, a strategic patience,
almost spiritual, that just
outlasts raw force.
That's such a powerful
distinction.
It really makes you wonder,
doesn't it?
Is true imposed external change
ever really possible, or is it
always just this temporary
veneer over an unyielding core?
Yeah.
Is it just surface stuff?
So it's not about winning every
single pitched battle, it's
about this more subtle, enduring
strategy for survival.
The source highlights
Afghanistan's mastery of
patients, it's uncanny ability
to simply wait out outsiders, no
matter how mighty they are, no
matter what they say they want
to do.
Yes, and this outlasting isn't
just passive waiting.
It's described as an active,
even deceptive, strategy.
Afghanistan, as the author puts
it, pretends to play along.
OK, what does that look like?
It means it readily accepts the
money, the aid, the resources
that these foreign powers bring
in.
It even allows pretty
substantial surface changes to
happen.
Like what kind of changes?
Well, you know, schools being
built using foreign money and
curricula, new laws being
enforced, at least in the
cities, foreign ideals,
democratic principles, modern
education ideas, different
social norms being promoted and
seemingly adopted in public
spaces.
So on the surface, it really
looks like change is happening,
like the invaders are
succeeding.
Exactly.
It looks like fundamental
transformation is underway, like
they're actually reshaping the
country according to their
plans.
But, and this is the crucial
bit, almost devious according to
the author, beneath this shiny
veneer of surface compliance,
the people remain deeply loyal.
Loyal to their tribes, their
local communities, their ancient
ways of doing things.
Their core identity stays strong
and hidden.
Hidden.
Wow.
They smile, they nod, they say
what the occupiers want to hear.
They might even benefit
personally from the influx of
cash or jobs.
But all the while, they're
fundamental cultural and social
core remains untouched,
resilient, just.
It's like a master class in
quiet internal resistance, A
societal deep breath held for
decades, maybe even centuries.
And this patient kind of
deceptive strategy, it has this
devastating, draining effect on
the invading force, the foreign
armies, the aid organizations,
the diplomats, they expend
immense energy pouring countless
resources, and critically,
slowly but surely, they lose
their willpower.
They get exhausted.
Totally exhausted, Frustrated by
the slow pace of what they see
as genuine change.
Worn out by the constant need to
prop things up.
Delusioned by the seeming
futility of it all.
And when the invaders finally
leave, drained, financially
depleted, defeated in spirit.
Afghanistan simply shrugs off
everything they tried to build.
Just like that shrugs it off.
Pretty much.
The effects are immediate and
dramatic, almost like a spell is
broken.
The schools that were built,
they close, or the curriculum
reverts.
The new laws, they just vanish,
become irrelevant overnight.
The new systems, the
institutions they tried to
create, they collapse like
houses of cars.
And Afghanistan, the deep
fundamental core of Afghanistan
remains unchanged.
It returns to its pre invasion
state with startling speed.
It's this powerful repeating
cycle absorption, then
rejection.
That's how it's beaten every
empire.
It doesn't need to win big
battles.
Exactly, According to the
source, it only needs to survive
long enough for its enemies to
give up, to get tired, to run
out of money or political will.
It buries their efforts in
silence.
The profound cultural attrition.
Which is precisely why it gets
called the Graveyard of Empires.
That makes a lot of sense.
So we've established Afghanistan
as this, this master of cultural
absorption and rejection, a
living testament to endurance
against overwhelming external
force.
Now here's where the article
takes it's truly surprising
turn.
It's central thesis.
Chris Abraham argues that
America does the same thing, but
to movements.
And initially, that sounds
incredibly counterintuitive,
doesn't it?
Yeah, it really does, America.
Is just such a vastly different
entity.
It's wealthy, it's modern,
powerful, a global leader, not a
poor tribal country being
invaded by armies over and over.
The conventional wisdom just
doesn't line up with this idea
that America could also be a
kind of graveyard.
Exactly.
We're used to thinking of
America as a country that leads
change, that influences others,
that undergoes its own dynamic
transformations through
political action, social
progress, innovation.
Right, the narrative is usually
one of progress, or at least
constant flux.
But the author here, Abraham, he
redefines what counts as an
invader in the American context.
It's not tanks and soldiers
rolling down Main Street.
Instead, it's movements.
Movements that arrive with a
different kind of force.
Protests, slogans, laws and
corporate campaigns, all driven
by this passionate mission to
change the culture from within.
So like cultural armies, in a
way, seeking to reshape the
American landscape of values and
norms.
Yeah, that's a good way to think
about it.
And what's really fascinating is
how America, according to the
source, responds to these
internal movements.
The pattern, Abraham argues, is
remarkably similar to how
Afghanistan interacts with
foreign powers.
Oh, so when a powerful movement
rises up, demands fundamental
change, asserts, you know, we
are going to transform America.
America, like Afghanistan,
simply plays along.
Plays along, it doesn't resist.
Well, not necessarily head on,
not always.
It appears to open the door
wide, almost welcoming the new
ideology or at least
accommodating it.
Very visibly.
The source describes this
massive influx of resources that
gets funneled towards supporting
these movements.
Companies may be eager to seem
relevant or just avoid bad PR,
throw enormous amounts of money
at them.
Sponsorships, donations,
internal DEI programs, that sort
of thing.
Right, corporate alignment
becomes a big signal.
Governments rewrite rules, pass
new legislation that seems to
align with the movement's goals.
Educational institutions from
K12 up to universities create
new programs, new curricula
designed to reflect the
movement's values.
So visible institutional
changes.
And citizens, maybe out of
genuine belief, maybe social
pressure, maybe just wanting to
show they agree, they repeat the
slogans, adopt A new language,
participate in the public
rituals associated with the
movement.
It creates this overwhelming
sense on the surface of
compliance even like
revolutionary transformation
happening really fast.
It goes further than just
compliance too.
There's an active reward system
that gets built into this
absorption process.
A reward system, Yeah.
People who vocally support the
movement, who adopt its language
and its principles, they often
find themselves rewarded.
New jobs, promotions, social
media praise, increased
influence awards.
So there are incentives to get
on board.
Exactly.
In this collective action, the
pouring end of resources, the
validation, the rewards, it
creates this powerful illusion
of complete and permanent
transformation.
On the surface, it looks like
America is completely getting in
to the movement's demands,
adopting its language,
implementing its policies with
surprising speed.
OK, I see the playing a long
part now.
It seems like total acceptance.
But in here's the crucial
parallel, the absolute core
inside of the article, just like
Afghanistan's deep identity,
remained hidden beneath the
surface compliance.
The author argues that in
America, this is only on the
surface.
Underneath it all, the percher
waits.
It's for.
What?
It just waits.
It takes the money, it takes the
changes.
It incorporates them on a
superficial level, maybe even a
performative level sometimes,
but it does not fully absorb
them into its deep core.
It pretends to be transformed,
while in some deeper, almost
subconscious societal way, it's
secretly preparing to return to
what it was before.
Like cultural mimicry looking
like the thing but not being the
thing.
Exactly.
Ultimately preserving the status
quo underneath.
So what does this all mean for
us?
You know, the listeners, as we
watch these big social shifts
happen, the source is suggesting
there's this deeply ingrained
societal mechanism at play here.
America isn't actively fighting
these movements head on like in
a cultural war battle.
Not fundamentally.
Instead, it's absorbing them in
a way that ultimately
neutralizes them.
It's like a kind of cultural
camouflage where the real
identity, the underlying inertia
of the system, stays hidden and
resilient beneath this veneer of
rapid but ultimately temporary
change.
And the author doesn't just make
this claim in the abstract,
right?
He backs set up with a pretty
extensive list of historical
examples showing this consistent
pattern.
Big surge service compliance,
then rollback in action.
Indeed, it's quite compelling
when you see them laid out.
The source illustrates this
pattern across a really wide
array of social and political
landscapes, suggesting this
consistent, almost cyclical
rhythm in American history.
It definitely challenges our
usual narratives of like,
straightforward linear progress.
OK, let's get into some of where
does the author start?
He goes back to the civil rights
movement of the 1960s,
obviously, undeniably big
victories there.
Huge victory Landmark
legislation Civil Rights Act 64
Voting Rights Act 65 Outlawed
segregation, prohibited
discrimination, dismantled legal
barriers for black voters.
Right On the surface, it looked
like a complete, permanent
transformation, A fundamental
reshaping of American Society,
dismantling centuries of
systemic oppression.
The energy, the protests, the
legal battles, it all led to
what seemed like this undeniable
victory that had fundamentally
changed America.
And for a time, those changes
were incredibly impactful.
They brought about profound
shifts in opportunity in public
life, no question.
Absolutely.
However, the source points out
that decades later, we saw this
quiet, kind of insidious
resegregation of schools
happening across the nation.
Now, so not by law, right?
No, not by overt law, more
through things like demographic
shifts, housing patterns, the
subtle but powerful influence of
economic inequalities.
Neighborhoods, even though
legally desegregated, largely
stayed divided along racial
lines in many places.
The initial energy, the
political will of the movement,
that relentless push for deep
integration.
It faded over time and the old
patterns, maybe in a more hidden
de facto form, began to creep
back.
It just shows how incredibly
challenging it is to truly
overcome that deep seated
cultural inertia.
OK, what's another example?
Then there's affirmative action.
Born out of that civil rights
era.
It was implemented to actively
give opportunities to millions
who'd been historically
disadvantaged.
Right Opening doors in
education, Jobs, government
contracts.
A direct step to level the
playing field.
It created real, tangible
pathways for advancement for
marginalized communities for
decades.
But overtime, we've seen its
gradual rollback.
Yeah, that's been a long
process.
Exactly.
Not a sudden repeal, but this
protracted process.
Decades of legal challenges
going way back to the Baker case
in the 70s limiting quotas up
through Grutter V Bollinger in
the early 2000s, which upheld
race as just one factor.
And public opinion shifted too
right.
Lots of debate about reverse
discrimination.
Influenced by political
narratives and then ultimately,
just recently, the Supreme Court
delivered what many see as the
final broad blow, effectively
ending its application in higher
education admissions.
So those initial gains, while
important, didn't embed
themselves permanently.
That seems to be the author's
point.
It's a textbook example of that
slow erosion he describes after
the initial surge.
OK, what about voting rights?
Also from the civil rights era?
Super critical.
Right initially strong for a
time, ensuring unprecedented
access to the ballot box,
especially in the South.
Federal power was used to
protect those rights, but again,
the source notes, they were
weakened piece by piece over the
years.
How'd it happen?
Through various means,
legislative changes.
Certainly a key moment was the
Supreme Court decision in 2013,
Shelby County V Holder, which
gutted a core provision of the
Voting Rights Act.
The pre clearance requirement.
Exactly.
That eliminated the need for
certain states with a history of
discrimination to get federal
approval before changing
election laws.
And that opened the door for a
wave of new state level
restrictions.
Like strict voter ID laws, voter
roll purges limiting early
voting.
All that stuff leading to new
obstacles that have in some
places made voting more
difficult.
Again, it just demonstrates how
even fundamental rights can be
eroded if the vigilance, the
energy of the movement that
secured them, starts to wane.
OK, moving to more contemporary
examples, Remember Occupy Wall
Street back in 2011?
Oh.
Yeah, burst onto the scene,
filled cities with protests
against economic inequality.
The whole 99% versus the 1%
thing, right?
It really put wealth to
disparity on the map, ignited a
national conversation.
It had immense public
visibility, seemed poised to
reshape the whole economic
discourse, introduced new
language shark critiques of
corporate power.
Then, as the source states, it
vanished almost overnight.
The camps dispersed.
The immediate media frenzy died
down.
The energy just dissipated.
Did it have any lasting impact?
Well, some of its language
definitely entered the lexicon
and it arguably influenced
subsequent movements.
But the systemic economic
changes it was demanding, they
largely didn't materialize.
The direct pressure points were
released and the system kind of
snapped back to its equilibrium.
OK.
And Black Lives Matter,
undeniably powerful, brought
global attention to racial
injustice, police brutality.
Huge, massive protests in 2014.
Then again, even bigger, in
2020, after George Floyd's
murder, widespread public
support, a real re evaluation of
law enforcement, cinemic racism.
Corporations issued statements.
Streets were painted.
The public discourse shifted
dramatically.
For sure.
Yet years later, Despite that
unprecedented surge of activism,
despite the widespread public
support at its peak, the source
argues that the systems it
fought against remain.
Meaning while there have been
some police reforms in certain
cities or States, and definitely
a heightened public awareness,
the fundamental structures the
move aim to dismantle haven't
seen the wholesale
transformation many had hoped
for.
That initial public and
corporate enthusiasm has in many
cases cooled off.
The deeper systemic changes
proved far more resistant once
the initial surge of energy
passed.
The pattern seems to continue
with even more recent, almost
current examples.
This really brings the author's
argument into sharp focus.
Like DEI programs, diversity,
equity and inclusion.
Right.
They became mandatory almost
everywhere it seemed, across
corporations, universities,
government agencies.
Happened remarkably quickly,
especially post 2020.
Looks like a permanent fixture,
you know, institutionalizing
these critical social values.
But the source highlights that
they are now being dismantled
quietly in many sectors.
Really.
We're seeing legislative
pushback in several states,
limiting or outright banning DEI
initiatives in public
universities and government
jobs.
Cororations are quietly scaling
back commitments, maybe
restructuring departments,
renaming programs often driven
by shifts in the economic
climate, or just wanting to
avoid political backlash.
So that widespread rapid embrace
was maybe more surface level
compliance.
That's the implication.
It's being peeled back, showing
that swift adoption doesn't
always mean deep
institutionalization.
It fits the pattern.
OK, woke activism is another
term the author uses.
Yeah, arguing it certainly
reshaped media and education for
a moment.
Influence content creation,
curricula.
Public discourse at a really
rapid pace led to quick changes
in what was seen as culturally
acceptable or progressive,
particularly around identity
issues, historical narratives.
Always a but.
But as the article notes, it's
now meeting huge backlash.
Significant countermovements
have mobilized.
There's a fierce cultural and
political pushback challenging
its core tenets, leading to
reversals or at least a
tempering of many of its
cultural impacts.
Suggesting the initial reshaping
wasn't fully absorbed or
accepted by the broader culture.
Exactly, suggesting a deep
powerful resistance was maybe
just waiting for the right
moment to assert itself again.
Trans rights campaigns.
They made massive cultural waves
over the past decade, right?
Unprecedented visibility pushing
for significant legal social
changes around gender identity.
Absolutely.
It felt like a really rapid
acceleration of acceptance
policy, changes in sports,
healthcare, legal recognition.
But then the reversal.
But then, as the source points
out, laws and policies are being
reversed across states at an
equally rapid pace, it seems.
So that initial surge met a
powerful rollback.
Yeah, through legislative bans
on gender affirming care for
minors, restrictions on bathroom
access, limitations on
participation in sports.
This stark reversal suggests
that even these profound
cultural shifts, while seeming
to gain huge ground quickly,
weren't permanently embedding
themselves the way it first
appeared.
They ran up against a powerful
countercurrent of existing
cultural norms.
Even something is like
universally impacting as the
COVID lockdowns.
Right Forced, absolutely
sweeping behavior changes.
Almost unimaginable adaptations
in how we worked, schooled, our
kids, socialized public health
mandates, masks, distancing,
vaccine pushes.
It was an unprecedented, almost
overnight shift in societal
norms, a real top down
imposition of change.
And yet, within two years,
America rejected them outright,
argues the author.
The willingness to comply with
restrictions just faded
dramatically.
Yeah, you saw mask mandates
dropped.
Vaccine skepticism grew.
A widespread, almost defiant
return to pre pandemic
behaviors, A rejection of
perceived government overreach.
It demonstrated this remarkable
societal snapback from intense
force changes, almost like the
collective body just expelled
something alien to its nature.
Climate change initiatives too.
Author says they consistently
serve.
Yeah, We see these periods of
intense focus, new policies
proposed like the Green New Deal
concept, public engagement
around environmental action,
joining agreements like Paris.
But then these efforts often
lose momentum.
They face political opposition,
industry pushback.
Economic concerns take
precedence, and they struggle to
achieve that lasting systemic
change needed.
It results in this cyclical
pattern.
Progress, then stagnation.
The deep inertia of fossil fuel
economies and establish energy
systems proves incredibly hard
to overcome in a sustained way.
And even right now, the author
points to free Palestine Rallies
dominate headlines capturing
significant public attention,
debate influencing political
discourse, massive
demonstrations, intense media
coverage, calls for policy
shifts.
But the author suggests, right
in line with this consistent
pattern he's been outlining,
that they too will fade.
Meaning the impact won't last.
Meaning, the intensity of public
focus, the widespread
demonstrations, the immediate
political pressure often
dissipate overtime without
necessarily leading to the
fundamental shifts in, say,
foreign policy that the movement
seek.
The core of decision making in
this analysis is just far more
resistant to a temporary surge
in public opinion.
OK, wow.
So here's where it gets really
interesting for you, the
listener.
This isn't just about one
movement or one issue.
No, the scope is broad.
The source is laying out this
repeating historical rhythm
across really diverse social and
political landscapes.
It forces you to look beyond the
daily headlines, beyond the
immediate reactions, and
consider the long game, the deep
currents beneath the surface,
the consistency of this pattern,
big surge, surface compliance,
and then rollback across so many
different kinds of issues.
That's what makes the author's
argument so, well, compelling.
Or at least provocative.
Yeah, it paints this picture of
America not as this perpetually
evolving entity always moving
forward, but as one with an
incredibly stubborn core, deeply
resistant to fundamental change.
OK, so this pattern, the surges,
the surface compliance, the
rollbacks, it isn't just random
according to the author.
He attributes it to these really
fundamental forces operating at
a societal level.
So let's shift to the why.
What are the underlying, almost
inescapable forces the author
says are at play here?
Right, he boils it down to two
key concepts drawn from physics
but applied to society.
Inertia and entropy.
Understanding these, even just
the basic idea, provides a kind
of foundational explanation for
why this pattern might keep
repeating.
It makes it feel less like a
series of coincidences and more
like maybe a law of social
interaction.
All.
Right, let's start with inertia.
In physics.
It's pretty simple, right?
A body at rest stays at rest
unless a big force moves it.
Exactly.
And a body in motion stays in
motion unless something stops
it.
It's that inherent tendency for
things to resist changes in
their state.
Think about pushing a really
heavy boulder.
Takes a lot of effort just to
get it moving.
Right.
And once it's moving, it wants
to keep going.
And conversely, it takes effort
to stop it.
It resists change.
So how does that apply
culturally?
Well, the cultural application
is critical here.
Cultures, the author argues,
work basically the same way.
They inherently resist change
unless an enormous continuous
effort pushes them.
So society is like that heavy
rock.
Kind of a society with all its
established norms, its
traditions, its institutions,
its power structures, its
ingrained beliefs.
It has immense inertia.
Even when it seems to be moved,
when it outwardly adopts new
ideas or behaviors, there's this
deep underlying tendency for it
to want to return to where it
started once that external
force, that push from the
movement diminishes.
Like a powerful gravitational
pull back to the status quo,
back to what feels familiar and
established.
Exactly.
Back to its resting state, you
can see.
OK, so that's inertia.
What about entropy?
Entropy in physics is often
described as the tendency
towards disorder, the slow
breakdown of things over time.
Order turns into disorder unless
energy is constantly added to
maintain the order.
Like a tidy room getting messy
if you don't keep cleaning it.
Perfect analogy.
Or think of a sandcastle on the
beach.
You build this ordered
structure, but the wind and the
waves, the natural forces, will
inevitably erode it, turn it
back into disordered sand,
unless you are constantly
putting in energy to rebuild and
maintain it.
OK, so how does that apply to
culture and movements?
Applied to culture, entropy
means that new systems, new
rules, and new habits decay if
they are not actively
maintained.
When a movement achieves a win,
a new law is passed, a new
program is created.
Public consciousness shifts in a
specific way.
That win is an ordered state.
It's a departure from the
previous state.
Right, it required energy to
create it.
Precisely.
But the moment the consistent
energy of a movement fades when
the activists go home, the
funding dries up, the media
moves on to the next thing.
Entropy, that natural force of
disorder and decay, begins to
erase its gains.
The same castle starts
crumbling.
Exactly.
The changes are simply not
self-sustaining without constant
upkeep.
They require continuous energy
input to resist that natural
tendency to decay back to the
previous state or just into
general disarray.
And the author argues these two
forces, inertia and entropy,
they don't just act separately.
No, they work in tandem,
creating this really formidable
barrier to lasting change.
Inertia keeps the core of
society, its deep seated values,
its traditional structures.
It's established power dynamics
largely the same, profoundly
resistant to fundamental shifts
like the heavy boulder.
While entropy is constantly
working to wear down anything
new that is built on top of that
core.
Precisely.
It's systematically eroding the
new structures, the new norms,
the new laws.
So no matter how strong the
initial push from a movement, no
matter how much energy it
generates in that surge, once
that energy runs out, once the
constant effort isn't applied
anymore.
Inertia pulls it back and
entropy wears it down.
Right.
These two fundamental forces
ensure that everything snaps
back to its old state, or close
to it.
The societal system just seeks
its lowest energy configuration,
which is usually its prior, more
comfortable, more established
state.
So if we connect this to the
bigger picture for you, the
learner, the author isn't just
throwing around abstract
scientific terms here.
No, the argument is that these
are fundamental laws governing
how societies change, or rather,
how they don't change in a truly
lasting way without constant,
immense, and frankly exhausting
effort.
It suggests a really profound
challenge for any movement
that's aiming for deep,
permanent societal
transformation.
Makes the whole prospect seem
much more daunting than we might
usually think.
Definitely changes the
perspective on activism and
progress.
So if inertia and entropy are
the why the fundamental forces
driving this pattern, let's talk
more about the how.
How does America actually do
this?
Absorbing and neutralizing?
The author brings back the
Afghanistan analogy here.
Afghanistan as the master of
patients.
Right, playing along with the
invaders, taking their
resources, just waiting for them
to get tired and leave.
In America, the article argues,
employs a strikingly similar,
maybe more passive but similar
waiting game with movements.
Yes, and this is where the
argument gets particularly
sharp, maybe even a bit
unsettling.
When a movement invades the
culture with its demands, its
protests, its push for new
policies, America's response,
according to the source, isn't
usually to directly fight it
head on with full force.
So what does it do instead?
Instead, the claim is America
gives it everything it asks for,
at least on the surface.
Everything like what?
It throws vast sums of money at
the cause or things associated
with it.
It lavishes media attention.
It provides official approval,
sometimes right from the top.
It even gives out easy wins.
Easy wins, like quick
legislative changes or companies
adopting slogans really fast.
Exactly.
Rapid corporate adoption of the
language.
Visible public endorsements?
Maybe some policy tweaks that
seem like big victories but
don't fundamentally alter the
core structures.
That's truly fascinating.
It's almost like the system is
designed to make the reformers
believe they're winning, maybe
even achieving total victory
really quickly.
That's one interpretation.
The movement pushes hard,
demanding radical change, and
the system appears to capitulate
quickly, adopting new policies,
programs, language with
surprising speed, apparent
eagerness.
And that can generate immense
excitement within the movement,
a belief that victory is just
around the corner.
But this strategy, the author
argues, surprisingly drains the
movement faster.
How does that work?
Well, think about the
psychology.
If a movement gets these quick,
surface level victories, it can
lead to a sense of premature
success, a feeling that the
hardest work is already done.
People might relax, the urgency
might fade.
Or conversely, it might spur the
movement to push even harder for
even more fundamental change,
believing the system is finally
weak or pliable.
But this constant high energy
expenditure, this cycle of
intense celebration followed by
renewed, even more demanding
pushes, it's just not
sustainable long term for a
social force.
The movement burns itself out
like a fire given too much
oxygen all at once.
Kind of.
It consumes all its fuel, all
its energy in this intense but
ultimately short lived burst.
And once the movement finally
runs out of strength, once that
initial energy is depleted, the
activists are exhausted, the
public attention moves on.
What happens then?
According to the author, America
then disperses whatever is left
of that energy into its massive
social system.
Disperses it like how?
It's described like this vast
complex Organism, maybe a
societal sponge that can absorb
and dilute any incoming force.
It spreads the energy so thinly
that it ceases to be a
concentrated transformative
power.
So the passionate activists
might get jobs within the very
institutions they were trying to
change.
Their sharp edges get dulled.
Perhaps, or the revolutionary
slogans become corporate tag
lines, stripped of their
original meaning.
The fervor gets metabolized,
integrated in a way that
neutralizes its radical
potential.
And the outcome, according to
this theory, is predictable,
Yeah.
The slogans fade, the policies
weaken, the attention shifts,
The initial excitement, the
changes it brought, they slowly
dissipate, not with a bang, but
with a whimper.
And crucially.
Crucially, the old patterns
return stronger than before
because that underlying cultural
inertia was never really
overcome.
The system simply reasserts its
preferred state.
After temporarily accommodating
the external pressure, it snaps
back.
And the author adds his point
about societal memory almost
like a collective sigh of
relief.
Yes, the culture, having been
through this intense period of
the movement, the disruption,
the arguments, the constant
demands for change, it remembers
how exhausting the movement was.
So it's not just that it returns
to the old state, there's a
resistance to going through that
again.
Exactly.
There's this quiet collective
sigh, maybe a deep, most
unconscious longing for
stability, for things to just
calm down, and it quietly hopes
that nothing like it happens
again soon.
This collective exhaustion
perhaps makes the next potential
invasion by a movement even
harder to get off the ground.
Wow.
OK, so this raises a really
important question for you, the
listener, to consider.
Is this whole process, this
absorption and neutralization,
is it a conscious strategy, like
a deliberate manipulation by
powerful people to neutralize
dissent?
Or is it just an emergent
property, something that happens
naturally in a complex system
like American Society, and
almost inevitable consequence of
those underlying forces, inertia
and entropy, acting on a large,
diverse, deeply ingrained
culture?
The author seems to lean towards
the latter.
Yeah, it's presented less as
some kind of malicious intent or
a grand conspiracy and more as
these fundamental, almost
unyielding laws governing social
change in this specific context,
almost like a societal physics.
It's a truly thought provoking
perspective.
It suggests this deep, almost
automatic mechanism is at play,
A societal immune system that
quietly but effectively fends
off attempts at radical
transformation.
It just absorbs the blows.
So to really solidify this whole
analogy, the author concludes by
reinforcing this powerful black
hole metaphor that was
introduced earlier.
Afghanistan is portrayed as a
black hole for empires.
Meaning it just swallows their
armies, their aid, and their
power.
Empires March in with all their
might, their resources, their
grand plans for transformation.
But Afghanistan ultimately
absorbs them without
fundamentally changing itself.
It leaves the invaders depleted,
their ambitions swallowed whole,
their efforts yielding Nothing
lasting.
They just disappear into the
Afghan landscape, metaphorically
speaking.
And then the mirror image
America is presented as a black
hole for movements.
Right.
It swallows their energy, their
reforms, and their victories.
Movements arrive with all their
passion, their demands, their
policy wins.
And America seems to consume
them much like a black hole
consumes light and matter.
So in both cases, the source
argues, the entity, whether it's
Afghanistan or America, absorbs
what it's given, be it military
might or social reform energy.
But crucially, it gives back
nothing lasting in terms of
fundamental, irreversible change
to its core identity.
The energy, the reforms, the
power, it all just disappears
into the system.
Dissipated, diluted,
neutralized.
Leaving the outside force,
whether it's an empire or a
movement, emptying confused,
wondering why their immense
efforts didn't result in the
permanent transformation they
expected.
Yeah, the impact gets absorbed,
but the core remains essentially
untouched.
It's a really powerful image,
isn't it?
Almost haunting this idea that
these immense forces, whether
military or cultural, just
vanish into some kind of
societal vacuum, leaving little
long term trace beyond a
temporary ripple on the surface.
It definitely forces you to
fundamentally reconsider how we
understand progress, how we
understand lasting change,
especially in the face of such
profound underlying forces like
inertia and entropy.
OK, so let's recap this
fascinating deep dive into Chris
Abraham's article America,
Afghanistan.
We've explored this truly
unexpected, maybe even jarring,
parallel.
Yeah, it's a lot to process.
With Afghanistan, the invaders
are literal armies.
They March in with weapons grand
plan, seeking to conquer and
transform, and ultimately they
leave defeated, their efforts
having vanished into the Afghan
landscape.
Right, the Graveyard of Empires.
With America, the author argues,
the invaders are movements They
March in with protests, new
policies, compelling slogans
demanding to reshape the culture
from within.
And in both scenarios, the core
mechanism as presented in the
article is remarkably similar.
Afghanistan gives that illusion
of compliance, takes the
resources outwardly, adjusts
only to quietly wait and outlast
until the invaders just exhaust
themselves and go home.
And America does much the same
with movements.
It appears to give them
everything they ask for.
Resources, public approval,
rapid surface level compliance
until their intense energy is
spent, the media spotlight moves
on and the movement burns itself
out or gets absorbed.
And in the end, in both cases,
the entity Afghanistan or
America effectively rolls back
the changes.
It sheds that temporary veneer
and returns to its original
fundamental state.
Or something very close to it.
Afghanistan is the graveyard of
empires.
America, this author posits, is
the graveyard of movements.
Both drain what tries to change
them.
Both seem to play a patient long
game, whether consciously or
not.
Both in their fundamental
essence, according to this
analysis, remain largely
unchanged, preserving their core
identity against these powerful
external and internal pressures.
This perspective, it truly
challenges our conventional
understanding of societal
evolution, doesn't it?
The effectiveness of activism.
Absolutely.
It compels us to ask if what we
often perceive as progress,
especially rapid progress, is
maybe just a temporary
oscillation around a very
stable, very deep seated
cultural core.
It certainly does.
So thinking about all this, if
this author's analysis holds
water, if America truly operates
as a kind of graveyard of
movements, what does that tell
us about the nature of deep
seated cultural change?
Does it mean true lasting
transformation is almost
impossible without perpetual
relentless energy, without
completely overcoming that
massive inertia and the constant
drag of entropy?
Or are there other forces, maybe
slower, more subtle forces, or
perhaps different approaches to
change altogether, that can
eventually overcome this
powerful cultural gravity the
author describes?
And maybe most importantly, what
does this perspective mean for
you, the learner, as you observe
the next big cultural surge, the
next societal debate unfolding
around you?
Are you witnessing genuine,
enduring transformation, a
fundamental shift that will
actually last for generations?
Or are you just watching another
cycle, another iteration of
absorption and eventual
rollback, destined to leave the
underlying system essentially
intact once the noise dies down?
It's definitely a question worth
pondering as you watch the
headlines unfold and engage with
the world around you.
Something to keep in the back of
your mind.